hello and welcome to this video
where we are going to talk about micro
carrier cultures
and their importance from an industrial
point of view
micro carrier cultures can be used to
obtain high yield culture of
anchorage dependent cells the
microcarrier culture
the cells grow in monolayers on top of
a sphere like structures known as micro
carrier beads
so this is a typical microcarrier beat
surrounding which
animal cells which are anchorage
dependent
can grow and proliferate there are
certain aspects
of this particular culture system let us
look at that
first of all the biggest advantage of
using this strategy
is the yield yield could be boosted
up to 200 million cells per milliliter
and that's a lot from an industrial
point of view
further surface characteristics have
been optimized for efficient attachment
of the mammalian cells
and such that these cells can grow
nicely on this surface
second size and density are optimized to
facilitate higher
yield lastly these beads are inert
so they do not really interact with the
cells and they are not toxic to the
cells
due to these characteristics these kind
of beads
are really interesting from an
industrial point of view when we want to
produce a lot of mammalian cells which
are anchorage dependent
now micro career culture can give rise
to high heat
but we have to understand what is the
real benefit
from an industrial point of view it is
difficult to scale up
anchorage dependent culture and the
biggest problem is the surface area
anchorage dependent cells grow on a
substratum
so if the surface is limited their
growth would be also limited
right and this kind of limitation can be
overcomed in the lab via several kind of
aspects
for example in the cell culture lab we
can use a bigger flask which has a
greater surface area
to overcome these challenges but what
happens in industry
when we have to produce millions of cell
and extract product out of them right
and we might have no choice other than
using anchorage dependent cell
in that kind of scenario how we can
scale up
our culture volume and the answer is my
using of micro carrier so this is a
normal culture
and this is a culture which uses a micro
carrier
when we use micro carrier cells can
grow on the substratum as well as
on the micro carrier beads simply
we have more cells growing in this
particular culture
when compared to a normal culture let us
look at a quick data
so this curve shows that using micro
carrier beads in a culture system
the cellular yield could be increased
several
folds and that is highly cost effective
beneficial from an industrial point of
view
now let us look at the advantages of the
micro
carrier culture system so they are
essential when the surface
surfaces are needed for anchorage
dependent cells
they are also inexpensive
next the micro carrier technology
results in homogeneous culture system
and that is really scalable lastly
because of their large surface area to
volume ratio
they occupy very less space in terms of
storage production
or waste handling so overall it has a
lot of advantage
now let me tell you about few specific
aspect where these kind of culture
systems
were used in order to produce vaccines
against
herpes simplex virus cytodex
microcarrier beads
were used in terms of production of
interferons which are used in several
immune therapies or cancer therapies
these kind of microcarrier beads are
really helpful
and in terms of generating monoclonal
antibody which has medicinal values or
therapeutic values
frequently micro carrier based cultures
are used in the
industry so we learned that micro
carrier based cultures are pretty
valuable from an industrial point of
view they might not be so interesting
from a laboratory point of view
but they are really interesting from an
industrial point of view where
there is a cost to benefit ratio so if
you like this video give it a quick
thumbs up
don't forget to check out all my
playlist you can follow me in instagram
or in facebook do let me know in the
comment if you have any suggestions
thank you